i'm sorry brother you are no brother to
me
nor to cleon the first nor to any other
cleon who walked these polish floors you
are a deformity and if i had my way you
would already be ash
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna
explain the ending of foundation season
one the season just wrapped up with the
release of episode 10 the leap and it
provided some answers to lingering
questions while setting things up for
the future of the series and season two
i'm going to look at what happened to
harry selden what does it all mean for
the foundation what happened to azor ah
and brother dawn and the conspiracy
there what will happen to the genetic
dynasty in demarzel and what happened to
gail and salvor hardin just a quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
the entire first season of foundation on
apple tv plus including the ending then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
episode 9 ended with the death of pharah
in the midst of the conflict between the
different factions of the outer reach
taking place on terminus harry selden
emerged from the vault and he seemed
alright with what was happening in the
finale we get a better understanding of
how he came to be there and what it all
means for psycho history in the
foundation he's a projection and he
explains to paulie who asked him if he
was the ghost that he took a pill that
contained millions of self-replicating
molecular machines those broke his body
down inside the coffin that he had made
and it recycled that material
transforming into the vault on its way
to terminus so the vault is actually
made of him but over those decades he
wasn't awake he wasn't sentient that
whole time he explains that his
reawakening was triggered by the
enacrian's arrival he says that it takes
time to rebuild consciousness and when
salvor tries to connect things to the
null field expanding he explains that
it's just part of the vault's natural
defenses harry addresses the anacrians
and thespins saying that they've hated
each other for so long that the origin
of their feud is almost irrelevant and
he explains that the first clone cleon
ii is responsible for setting things in
motion the generations of hate between
these two cultures that we saw was
ongoing in episode 1 when they came to
trantor all traces back to what's called
the first betrayal where cleon ii had
his shadow master murder an anacrian
grand huntress and blame it on the
thespian king she just married the point
was that this marriage was gonna bring
together these two emerging powers in
the outer reach and that would be a
threat to the empire's power so the
emperor decided to undermine that
knowing that it would get them to fight
each other and then he wouldn't have to
deal with it now harry says he needs
them to put that behind them and come
together he selected the original
colonists on terminus to have the seeds
of a future civilization and the others
are survivors they've been cast aside by
the empire and they're still there under
the genetic dynasty there's only room
for one story and one voice and he
believes that that stagnation guarantees
that the empire will fall and that will
be followed by a dark age that lasts 30
000 years it was always part of his plan
for these three cultures and the outer
reach to come together he explains that
he found the pattern in the jumps of the
invictus and that they're discovering it
would be a potential step ahead for the
foundation's development he explains
that the idea of them curating knowledge
for the encyclopedia was only a cover
story the foundation was never about
that it was about curating people and
when one of the foundationers echoes
what he says about them not being
revolutionaries he says that he may have
lied about that point there's still a
problem in that the empire is still
going to come investigate what happened
to dorwan's ship who was there in the
first place to investigate what happened
to the coms buoy harry tells them that
they won't come if they think they're
already dead and he tells them to use
the invictus to create a false mega
flare something like that would wipe out
all life in the system and therefore
there would be no reason for them to
come into a situation where there might
be a dangerous star and a bunch of dead
planets even if it did host the
foundation at one time after that if
they don't leave the outer reach they
would be invisible and more importantly
they would be free they can bide their
time build up their strengths and become
what they need to be to shorten that
period of darkness according to psycho
history
as he gets ready to return to the vault
they ask if they'll see him again he
expects that to be the case because this
isn't the foundation's first crisis and
it won't be the last they bought
themselves some time but war with empire
is inevitable he tells them to remember
this day remember what they're striving
for and remember that a thousand years
can seem like a long time but it's only
a blip on the history of civilization
and if they're not vigilant this
opportunity that they have could slip
right through their fingers as he was
talking he realized gail wasn't there
and that she never made it to terminus
in that exchange he meets salvor but
it's clear that he didn't anticipate her
or know who she was so as he's leaving
she asks him about the visions that
she's been having and he doesn't know
what she's talking about she explains
that she used them to help her solve the
crisis and he assures her the divisions
didn't come from him and then the
projection goes back inside the vault
and it closes up and it looks like it
did beforehand
so what does it mean for the foundation
we see that the cultures are willing to
work together there's an exchange where
rowan gives the grand huntress his boat
to salvor in an act of peace and they
plant a sapling from an acrion together
at the site of pharah's burial mari and
the other foundationers are angry they
feel betrayed and it's not so much that
harry didn't tell them what was going to
happen but that he lied to them salvor's
in a similar situation she grew up
thinking that the ghost was talking to
her that harry selden was talking to her
through the vault she started to believe
that she was special and now she has no
idea where the visions were coming from
there's a time lapse of the colony
growing over the next few months
everyone has come together and they're
taking harry's words to heart setting
aside their hatred in favor of strength
and moving forward with the foundation
they repair the invictus and hugo
becomes the captain he goes out and
generates the mega flare allowing them
to be free and now that they have the
technology we learn that it'll take them
about 18 months until they can start
building new ships for her crucial role
in the crisis salvor is set to become
the next mayor but she has another
vision where she sees a young guy she
goes to see her mother asking her about
who the girl from the water planet was
this leads to the big reveal that gail
and rach were her biological parents and
the visions were related to their
memories rather than harry she knows
that gail escaped the slow ship in a
cryopod and decides that she needs to
leave terminus and go look for her she
decides she wants to leave right away
because she's afraid that she'll change
her mind and her mother gives her her
blessing and the prime radiant to take
with her she goes to the beggar and hugo
finds her before she leaves they have
their goodbye and we get an
understanding of where her head's at she
thinks this is something that she needs
to do alone and when he asks where she's
going she just says that she has a hunch
and she leaves
as has often been the case in this first
season where things get really
interesting is on trantor and what
happened to azorra brother dawn and the
conspiracy brother day has returned to
the planet and his trip to the maiden
has changed his thinking brother dusk
wants to destroy dawn and replace him
and when dae goes to talk to him he says
you're not one of us your dna has been
altered in a dozen ways he wants to know
how long he's known and this brings
about a really interesting conversation
about how they aren't even really people
they're just echoes of the first cleon
and hasn't dey himself ever wanted to
leave this place be something more than
just an installment in this ongoing
story
when he goes to speak with azor ah he
explains that he understands that people
hate him but says that his detachment
from them is what makes it possible for
him to rule effectively it's a strange
burden not being able to carry a burden
the brothers care for each other they
love each other and they shift that
burden between each other he views don
as his son he rocked him as a baby he
cultivated him and azora took all of
that away from him so he wants to take
away her legacy and they located every
person family friends lovers and so on
anyone that would remember her after she
was gone it's a total of
1551 people they have them all under
surveillance and there's a particle beam
focused on their brain stem so that when
he gives the signal they'll all be
killed and right after he explains this
he gives the signal so they're all dead
he then tells her what her fate will be
she'll be put into automated extreme
isolation where she'll be sensory
shrouded but she'll still be aware and
he's doing that so that she can remember
what she took from him and it's a brutal
fate no matter how you look at it
demerizel comes to dawn she tells them
it's time and on their walk to the
throne room he says that she must hate
him she assures him that's not the case
she actually loves him and when he says
that it's only because she's programmed
to she explains that all love is
programmed biological or otherwise
saying that when a human mother looks at
her child their brain waves synchronize
when he's brought before dusk and day
it's clear that dusk hasn't changed his
mind at all but he has to default to the
middle throne brother day explains on
his trip he had much time to reflect on
their dynasty he talks about the
pilgrims he met who worked their whole
lives just to walk a spiral of salt in
hopes that they might be granted a
vision before they die he talks about
the challenge from halima he brings up
harry selden how he prophesies something
similar and declares that a bow and
capable of bending will eventually break
he says it's time the dynasty bent just
a little brother dusk is not willing to
go along with this and they start
fighting he's convinced that it'll ruin
their dynasty and he threatens to decant
another day rather than allowing the
altar dawn to live as they continue to
fight dawn goes to demisel for
protection and she holds him like a
child stroking his hair brother dust
shouts we are empire history bends to us
and as he's saying that demmerzell snaps
brother dawn's neck killing him
instantly when brother day protests
yelling no she tells him that she's
loyal to the clionic dynasty above all
else after he disintegrates the body the
shadow master comes to him to say that
the rebels plans to undermine the
dynasty appear to be more extensive than
they first believed they thought the
gene editing was limited entirely to
brother dawn's person and that it was
done after he was incarnated which is
what the other clone told him whenever
he was in the scar after more testing
though they found out that the source
itself was adulterated as were the
replacements those are no longer pure
copies so the source material is gone
brother dawn is dead and they can't
replace him with another pure clone even
they himself could be altered they don't
know that yet as well as brother dusk
who's being tested right at that moment
he sends the shadowmaster away and in a
rage he smashes the glass case
containing the original clion the first
then demmerzelle goes back to her room
takes off her salt bracelet and looks in
the mirror she looks troubled she opens
her kit and grabs a tool before tossing
it aside and then tears her face off as
she screams and with a lot of unanswered
questions about the future the trantor
storyline ends there so what happened
with gail and salvor hardin well we get
one last scene that takes place 138
years later we see gail arrive on cenex
she's able to find her home there's no
signs of life there anymore maybe not
any on the planet at all as we see that
the water is much higher as she's
mourning she sees a light under the
water and decides to go find out what it
is it turns out to be the beggar and
inside she finds salvor in a cryopod she
gets her out of the water and wakes her
up and when she asks her what happened
she explains that she crashed landed
she's been in cryosleep for more than a
century and says that she was there
looking for someone which of course she
was looking for gail and she tells her
i'm salvor hardin your daughter and then
she hands her the prime radiant and the
episode ends there
so in the end where are we at the
foundation survived the first crisis and
came out of it with an alliance in the
outer reach that will make them stronger
one version of harry selden's
consciousness exist inside the vault to
be a reassuring presence at the very
least the initial reason he got the
encyclopedist exiled determinus was a
lie but things appear to be on course
for the plan in psycho history should
serve its purpose to shorten the dark
age that will come after the fall of the
galactic empire periodic crises are
baked into that and harry should
re-emerge accordingly gail and salvo are
mother and daughter and they have these
unique abilities they don't quite
understand they're together but their
future is uncertain considering they
have the prime radiant i have some ideas
based on what i know from reading the
books but i won't go into those here
their being on cynix means that they're
somewhat isolated but considering the
foundation has at least one jump ship
now they could be reconnected without
another prolonged period of cryosleep
either way enough time has passed that
things are completely different on
terminus and it's gonna take time for
that story to catch up to where they're
at the clionic dynasty also has an
uncertain future the only thing that
seems certain is that it won't be
carrying on like it has for the last 400
years they left things pretty wide open
as far as whether brother dusk and
brother day were altered and there
really wasn't any progress as far as
finding out who's behind the conspiracy
demarzelle's final scene was fascinating
and i think one of my next videos will
be talking about what i think's going on
there for now it appears that cleon the
first altered her programming to be
loyal to the clionic dynasty above all
else and the things that she has to do
in relation to that or taking a toll on
her it'll be interesting to see how she
responds to the dilemma of having no new
clones or pure genetic material to
continue the dynasty as they've known it
for a review this first season had its
issues especially in the structure and
pacing of the early middle episodes
overall the terminus storyline was
noticeably weaker than the story with
the cleons and there were places where
it just didn't work for me i'm sure some
of that can be chalked up to the
pandemic but it also felt to me that
they defaulted to try to do a cool
action thing in a lot of situations with
mixed results i do give them credit for
the effort though looking back they did
a lot of crazy things
and i think generally speaking it's
always good to see a show that takes
chances and i'm hoping that they'll be
able to identify what worked and what
didn't and come back with a much
stronger effort in the second season
there was a lot of effort to develop the
characters and again i think this worked
a whole lot better on the trantor side
of things but as far as the finales
concerned it felt like a step up across
the board in that department so at least
it feels like they're going in the right
direction there even with having so many
different stories that all felt somewhat
different to tie up in one hour-long
episode from asimov they've got a
toolbox to pull from that includes some
great twists and turns based on psycho
history and the part they introduced
themselves the genetic dynasty has
turned out to be a great addition they
managed to pull off some great sci-fi
and character stuff at the same time
there's so much rolled up in that
dynamic and i'd loved the progression of
brother day through his trip then coming
back to his interactions with dusk and
dawn and azora respectively only to be
completely invested in what was going on
in his decision and then actually
shocked at what demarzel did the thought
of brother day being on the verge of
changing things only to have it snatched
away by a fail-safe that we have to
assume was instituted by the original
cleon that was the highlight of the
season the most powerful person in the
galaxy is trapped in that cycle there's
really nothing they can do to change
things and now there's no way to
continue that so even with the issues it
had i'm pretty happy with where we're at
i'm curious to see where they go from
here and i'm glad i watched it and i'm
happy that they made it it was ambitious
and sprawling and you can't take that
away from it this thing was huge in
scope and budget it was a proper
spectacle at times and there's a lot to
like there if you go looking for it and
i think that's a good place to leave
things i do have a lot of questions
though and i'll be following this up
with a season two questions video
sometime during this week so let me know
what questions you have for that in the
comments and let me know what you
thought of the season what you thought
of the finale and if you want to talk
book spoilers just make sure you mark
them please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon